amateur terrorist attacks and soap made
from liposuction fat Fight Club can be a
confusing ride but we're here to help
the first two rules of Fight Club are to
never talk about Fight Club but the film
itself also has a rule never reveal the
narrator's name the film avoids
mentioning the name of the protagonist
who's only called narrator in the ending
credits the character stays nameless so
that he can represent anyone who has
lost their sense of self and
individuality Fight Club cleverly
references his lack of a name when he is
simply addressed as Sir by members of
the club the film goes as far as to give
him multiple names as he attends various
support groups under aliases Marla
singer even asks him about it when they
first meet doesn't have your name who
are you Cornelius Rupert Travis any of
the stupid names you give each night
meanwhile the narrator frequently uses
the phrase I am Jack's sense of to
express how he's feeling at any given
time this is a reference to articles
that he reads early in the film I am Jax
medulla oblongata without me Jack could
not regulate his heart rate blood
pressure or breathing the text on the
Fight Club DVD as well as its bonus
features refer to the character as Jack
and the chapter list for the film is
called Jack's chapters the character is
also referred to as Jack in the official
shooting screenplay which Norton
confirmed in the DVD commentary of the
movie
you would never describe Marla's
relationship with the narrator as
healthy Marla regularly expresses her
frustration with the narrator's behavior
towards her you know you are such in
that case I can't even begin
even the narrator doesn't know that he's
in a sexual relationship with her until
he realizes that he himself is Tyler
Durden with whom Marla has been having
sex before that realization the narrator
doesn't seem to like her as a person and
therefore Tyler doesn't respect her
viewers would wonder among other things
why Marla would continue to stay with
the narrator with everything he's
putting her through it's established
that the chain smoking Marla has grown
accustomed to Leading a self-destructive
lifestyle possibly to the point that she
views toxic relationships as normal this
might come from the character's low
self-esteem which makes her drawn to the
narrator especially after he intervened
as she tried to end her own life
after the narrator meets Tyler Durden on
the plane he's drawn to the mysterious
soap salesman who seems to be the
complete opposite of himself there are
times before their initial encounter
when the narrator may not have noticed
Tyler's presence but audiences have with
the exception of the first time Tyler is
clearly seen on the escalator he's only
briefly visible to eagle-eyed viewers in
single frame flashes given that Tyler
was likely controlling the narrator's
body while he slept these single frame
flashes could be remnants of his
memories while sleepwalking the
explosion at the narrator's condo was
caused by Tyler and it happened before
they met on the plane this implies that
Tyler had been plotting and acting
before he ever met the narrator on the
plane
the first rule of Fight Club is you do
not talk about Fight Club
and despite that also being the second
rule of Fight Club the club not only
continues to attract new members but
eventually transforms into Project
Mayhem an anarchist organization run by
Tyler even though Tyler scolds the club
for breaking the rule he doesn't seem to
mind that it's growing after all
breaking the rules is what fight Club is
all about when the narrator runs into
Bob after a long time Bob is excited to
talk all about a new club he's attending
Wow
first rule is
talk about it the narrator tells him
that he's part of the same Club too and
they talk about fight club without
saying its name it's possible to imagine
that word of Fight Club spreads like
this with people talking about the club
as though it were a support group for
them which it arguably was
Fight Club and Project Mayhem eventually
grow to include hundreds of members over
multiple cities functioning as an army
with plans weapons and explosives
Project Mayhem aims to bomb several
credit card company buildings an
operation which would have to take a lot
of money so how did Tyler and his army
find the funds needed to support such a
massive undertaking to finance Fight
Club Tyler had been making luxury soap
from the fat dumped in the garbage
facilities of liposuction clinics which
he would sell for 21 a piece still since
Tyler seems to be the sole proprietor of
his small-scale soap business he
wouldn't generate enough Revenue alone
to support the club Project Mayhem
doesn't just sell soap to make money
though the narrator even blackmails his
boss with compromising information about
their company in exchange for a full
salary and perks as an outside
consultant while this provides one
source of income it still doesn't
explain how Project Mayhem could afford
to pull off their master plan however it
is pretty likely that project mayhem's
many members may have contributed their
own earnings to support the club's
movement
at the climax of the film Tyler appears
to have the upper hand on the narrator
since Tyler doesn't really exist and
therefore can't be hurt however the
narrator eventually realizes that if
Tyler is holding a gun so is the
narrator himself he turns the tables by
taking control of Tyler's gun himself
into finding a new way to deal with
Tyler by shooting himself the gunshot
wound isn't fatal enough for the
narrator to pass out he can still talk
to his soldiers and Marla although
barely the more you think about it the
more questions arise about the logic of
Tyler's death what specifically causes
Tyler Durden who exists only in the
narrator's head to believe that he has
been killed by a single Bullet to the
narrator's jaw one explanation is that
the entire final showdown is more of a
mental struggle within the narrator's
head than it is a physical one after
realizing that he is ultimately the one
in control the narrator shoots himself
non-fatally in order to finally get rid
of Tyler once and for all thank you
with the tagline Mischief Mayhem soap
and the film's title inscribed on a pink
soap bar soap was a key aspect of the
marketing and plot of the film The
narrator is introduced to Tyler Durden a
seemingly successful luxury soap
entrepreneur only after spending more
time with Tyler and getting to know him
better does the narrator learn the
gruesome way Tyler makes his soaps while
soap is a cleaning agent the history of
soap manufacturing is unpleasant in
ancient Mesopotamia soap had been made
by cooking fats obtained from
slaughtered animals along with being
symbolic of this sacrifice soaps also
have a history of being a luxury item
only being available to European
aristocracy Tyler who despises wealth
and vanity sells soap made from the fat
of rich people to the very same people
later and no one's the wiser it fits
into his anti-capitalist Mantra
perfectly which is why it's used as an
icon for the movie itself
to anyone watching Fight Club for the
first time the few single frame blips
that appear in the initial few minutes
of the film can be disorienting and
confusing it's only after a second watch
when you may realize it was Tyler who
blipped in these frames which is
something Tyler does at his job in the
film itself if you pause on the frames
you would see Tyler striking relaxed
poses as though he were foreshadowing
his meeting with the narrator it's also
possible that Tyler had been operating
behind the narrator's back whenever the
narrator was asleep Tyler's memories and
personality may have begun to bleed into
the narrator's conscious mind which may
be why Tyler finally introduces himself
to the narrator in Marvel's Moon Knight
a similar situation occurs in a more
modern setting Mark Spector had been
able to function without Steven Grant
being aware that he has a second
personality but eventually it wasn't
possible to keep that a secret from
Steven anymore it's interesting to note
that both Steven Grand and fight club's
narrator have troubles with insomnia
which play into their alternate
identities as Moon Knight and Tyler
Durden
Marla's frustration with the narrator
should have been one of the first Clues
toward fight club's big twist that he
and Tyler Durden are the same person
upon re-watching the film it becomes a
kind of game to find the moments and
scenes where the narrator was actually
Tyler Durden the film uses his
behavioral changes intentional
continuity errors and other Easter eggs
planted to indicate to the audience
which is which one clear example of the
narrator being more Tyler than himself
happens when the narrator's boss
confronts him on his erratic Behavior
since joining Fight Club the narrator
responds rudely and threatens his boss
and this button-down Oxford cloth psycho
might just snap and then stalk from
office to office pumping round after
round in the colleagues and co-workers
this kind of intimidation seems out of
character for the usually Meek narrator
and is similar to Brad Pitt's unsettling
portrayal of Tyler Durden while Tyler's
attitude and manner of Life are supposed
to be influencing him it appears that
the narrator is almost being possessed
by Tyler in this scene it's also
interesting to see that the narrator's
goatee-like stubble in the sequence
matches that of Tyler's
[Music]